In this lesson, we will talk
about system virtualization.
It's another important component of the
system software stack that's involved
in the management of
the physical resources.
We will explain what is virtualization
and why it is important.
And we will discuss what are some of the
key technical approaches that are part
of popular virtualization solutions,
such Xen and KVM and VMware CSX.
In addition,
at the end of the lesson we will discuss
what are some of the hardware advances
that have occurred over the last decade
in response to virtualization trends.
Specifically in the context
of the x86 architecture.
A lot of the content in this lecture is
also summarized in a paper by Rosenblum
and Garfunkel.
Virtual Machine Monitors,
Current Technologies and Future Trends.
Note that this is a paper from 2005,
so much more has happened in
the virtualization space than what
this paper what this paper describes.
But it gives,
does serve as a useful reference.